what up space fam goes in here from
anime uproar and I decided to make a
video about the latest insane
developments in the one piece story I
can't remember the last time I felt this
much hype during one chapter so
definitely stay tuned for that if you
want to see more one piece chapter
reviews make sure to smash that like
button to let me know if you haven't be
sure to subscribe and this is crucial
hit that notification bell or you will
miss future one piece of videos we
already got a one piece playlist on this
channel including recent videos about
the Yong Co and the warlord so
definitely check that out I'll leave a
link to the playlist in the description
and at the end of this video keep in
mind there will be manga spoilers we are
talking about the latest one piece
chapter chapter 974 after all now
without further ado let's jump into this
epicness so this chapter is called
onward to onigashima which is already
hyped because that's where kaido's
headquarters are we are approaching the
rematch with a young KO and now Kaito
has teamed up with big mom the two
living Yong chol with the highest
bounties we start with a flashback of
danger on Hiyori and we're told that
these two have been hiding for a long
time in fact it was only recently that
we found out that Yoshino was actually
densha the scabbard this whole time
here we have some stuff explained then
Jiro had Hiyori prepared with fake blood
when the time came or not she had no
idea that she was a daughter of Odin but
he was crazy about her then general
wanting to protect her from a rod she
decided the best way to separate her
from Orochi was to stage her death
thus when he asked her if she was ready
to die in chapter 933 and she said she
was we now know that he was actually
talking about this plan with the fake
blood he was taking care of her keeping
a close eye on her as they waited
together for the 20 years to pass before
they could all finally get revenge on
Orochi and Kaito dendro is such an
interesting character and the fact that
he kept his identity a secret from
everyone else including his allies is
genius as we'll see in a little bit this
was a wise and necessary move he kept
his enemies closer than his friends and
had to deceive his allies in order to
deceive his enemies the level of
discipline and patience something like
that takes is unreal then we jump to an
orgy initially getting news of the
scabbards and Momo knows
returning after 20 years he's scared
because Toki's power was real she could
really send people to the future and
save them from the burning building he
got the letter with this information
from the trader all thought she promises
Kaito that they can trust him the trader
was born into a family of actors and his
parents died on stage during the
repression of wah no during the murder
someone said this is the line of the
Dinos killer
we know that the head of the ku resumee
family tried to poison the other daimyo
in order to get power for themselves so
this would suggest that the trader is a
KU resuming because of the head of the
family's actions the kudos Umi family
members were hunted down and brutally
killed whether they had anything to do
with the initial plot or not this is why
the traitors parents were killed on
stage what she tells us that the traitor
only knew life on the stage so he would
be perfect for the job
he had more experience acting than being
a real person so who better to pull off
a convincing performance or don't she
gave the trader a devil fruit and told
him that he will live like a real Kazuki
and without being noticed by anyone he
would die like a Kazuki what she says
that this is the great role that the
trainer will play until the end and the
trader accepts it saying he was just
looking for a way to die it appears that
the trader is so messed up that his only
satisfaction is being someone else
entirely it's a very interesting idea an
artist committing to the gray role and
even being willing to die in the
execution of their artistic role and
yeah there are a lot of clues here to
who the traitor is
but let's carry on for now even to
Orochi this trader is crazy because he
was really ready to die with Odin and
the others during the execution for
someone who's scared of everything like
Orochi this really doesn't make sense
it's terrifyingly convenient and
unbelievable for Adachi how the trader
lives as the perfect close uki vassal
while sending information with no fuss
such a character is truly fascinating
and you don't come across them often a
character who's willing to commit so
completely to a role this is the den
judo aka the double agent on the enemy's
side drawing a nice parallel within the
story and making everything that's going
on crazier and more intricate then we
jump to the present exactly twenty years
after the
Bohdan we're told that this is the story
of the Kazuki and kudos Umi clans and
the pyro Kaito and that they're deeply
linked we're reminded Odin's goal was to
open up Wan oh and the samurai have
jumped 20 years in the future in order
to do that they've also devoted
themselves to gathering allies for the
fight including the straw hats I find
this very interesting about the wah no
arc it's positioned at times as if the
straw hats are side characters in the
main story about wonho's people rather
than the main characters this approach
really foregrounds how well Oda flushes
out to the world of one piece and all of
its actual side characters because of
the depth he gives them we start to care
a lot about the characters of Wan o and
their fate although I do miss the straw
hats when they're not in chapters it's
necessary for them to step back from the
limelight so the emotional climax of
this art can be fully felt older doesn't
just want us to want Luffy to win
separate from Luffy he wants us to want
the good guys we've met from 102 win as
well and by this point we're really
rooting for the people who carry on
odin's will combine that with how much
we want the straw hats to win and the
emotional stakes couldn't be much higher
we are reminded that 4200 people should
have regrouped at the port
but this idealistic image of the huge
number of people hyped up to fight is
contrasted with the cold wet reality the
flashback and all this time in Hua no
have been leading up to this moment and
the people who were supposed to show
aren't there we got some waves drawn in
a style that you'd recognize from
Japanese art like the Great Wave of
Kanagawa within the 100 arc Oda seems to
be regularly giving a tribute to Japan
and its artistic history through his
drawings our characters are practically
dots that can barely be seen they're
dwarfed by their surroundings and the
untamed waves this panel reflects how
powerless our guys must feel right now
in this way just like Shakespeare does
Oda is giving us a great example of
pathetic fallacy at work where the
weather is really giving us a lot of
information about how the characters
feel the scabbards present won't let
momonosuke stop them even if the others
didn't show they're gonna fight they
won't let everything that led up to this
moment and all of the sacrifice
be for nothing trying to comfort
momonosuke the Scabbers tried to reframe
the lack of manpower by saying that the
small group will give them a chance to
sneak up on Kaito and cut off his head
however those words are not too
comforting when you know that Kaito has
survived worse than a sword to the neck
many times
however they are truly brave and they
vow to not give up as long as they live
Shinobu and momonosuke are seen shutting
tears in the rain while the others head
Tokaido then the idea of a traitor is
brought up kena moon says he didn't want
to think about it but there's definitely
an enemy spy among them he even says
that not to point there at he doesn't
even want to know who it is
the situation seems so hopeless already
the last thing they want to do is
confront the betrayal of one of the few
people they trust before they die
kikunojo though won't accept that she
wants ki naman to find a snitch so they
can move on but rather than thinking
about it Kim Amon says that the traitor
won't reveal themselves and yeah traders
usually won't that's kind of the point
finally a crying chondral has to admit
that he's the traitor since no one seems
to want to accuse each other Kenan one's
face really shows his shock it seems
like a joke since they were all
condemned to boil 20 years ago and the
even crazy by otogi standards kanjuro
admits that it's exactly by dying with
them that he would have completed his
role to perfection as a kid he lost his
heart probably what his parents were
killed before him and since then he's
been looking for a place to die from the
start it was all the act of a master
actor a lot of this makes sense
he ate the devil fruit or or she gave
him with it he could create drawings
that would help him communicate with
orochy he's actually dressed as a kabuki
performer which reflects the fact that
he's been performing this whole time
because of his devil fruit powers he's
associated with art and who else would
be willing to carry out a performance
even if it costs them their lives but an
artist bent on giving a brilliant
performance still despite the fact that
it was heavily hinted at and I only
named a few clues the reveal still has
impact rivals reaction is the best with
his nose running over time Kandra
reveals that he spent happy hours with
them he has no resentment and never
desired to her
he just passed on info to Orochi when
pressed as to why he did it he reveals
that he's a cool zooming so it does make
sense that he'd have a grudge against
the Kazuki's Kandra then tries to
suggest that yas who died for nothing
since conjurer just snitched about the
change of time and place
he points out how the other scabbards
had clues and they were even suspicious
but no one actually did anything about
it even though they should have known
that he was a mole he's rubbing it in
and we see beasts pirate ships
approaching keen em one can't take any
more in cuts conjurer's head off but it
was just a drawing the real control has
actually taken momonosuke hostage at the
port he would have gladly fought with
them to the debt to complete his role
but Orochi told him that it was the end
of the show and to capture momonosuke
on top of that so he finally dropped his
mask the performance was so good that he
managed to convince everyone that he was
bad at drawing even though he was
excellent this way no one would suspect
him to not be on the boat
and he could get away with creating any
creature that he drew weld because it
would go undetected he exaggerated how
bad he was at drawing so that no one
would suspect him and in a series like
one piece we the readers are trained to
accept that there are plenty of funny
comedic relief characters like that so
even we were trained to let her guard
down and just assume that he was bad at
drawing oda pulled a fast one on all of
us up until now this chapter has been
amazing but it starts to get even better
a shot goes off and hits an enemy ship
we see luffy scar and he says sorry we
are a little late next the submarine
comes up picking up our samurai along
the way they're rebuked a bit for under
estimating the sea and using such a tiny
boat and then we see lost tattoos
another shot is fired at the enemies
from the other side and although you
can't see this pirates face either it's
clearly Captain Kidd he says there are
many samurai and boats waiting like
idiots on the opposite port there are
reinforcements and the sky birds are
relieved to find out the Luffy's finally
arrived this trio of the worst
generation are back together again and
they straight up plan to attack the
allied yong-chol Kaito and thus big bomb
Kandra shocked not expecting this the
beast pirates
they just have to sink one small boat
with some samurai on it but now they got
to face three of the pirates from the
worst generation Luffy calls the Pirates
out for taking on a small boat of
samurai and says that see we deal with
pirates we get panels of each of the
trio side by side law luffy and kid and
dear lord the hype is real
we finally have Luffy back we got law
and damn does he look cool here and we
got kid to boot an epic hype storm of an
alliance and they're going to take on
Kaito and big mom the two freaking Yong
Co with the two biggest frickin bounties
right now if these guys really take down
to Yong ko then one piece could escalate
very very quickly after this let me know
in the comments what do you think is
gonna happen next do you expect some
other players here these guys are
awesome but we are talking about Kaito
and big mom here Luffy looks confident
here after his previous defeat but I
think we have to see even more help
coming their way
we know that Blackbeard is amazing at
taking advantage of opportunities so I
wouldn't be surprised if he showed up to
help them take down Kaito and big mom
two of his biggest rivals we also saw
Moria with him and he's been wanting
revenge on Kaito and what better time
for that than now so we may well see
Blackbeard in Moria show up and with
that many onco shanks might even
freaking make an appearance who knows at
this point right now the sky's the limit
as to what can happen and I could not be
more hyped for the next chapter I do
think that the WHA no story was well
done but I gotta admit it feels so good
that Luffy my boy law and the rest are
finally back and headed straight for the
Kaito fight no less this could be right
up there with the battle at marine fort
or even surpass it so let's just say I'm
very much looking forward to the
upcoming chapters and that is it for
this chapter review thanks for listening
if you enjoyed it make sure to smash
that like button to let me know if you
haven't be sure to subscribe and this is
crucial
hit that notification bell or you will
miss future one piece videos and let me
know in the comments if you do want to
see more of these reviews on a weekly
basis a special thank you goes to our
patrons over on patreon who help us
survive YouTube issues and who helped
make videos like this one possible first
and foremost I want to thank our the one
tear
the ones who stand atop all clans
Stephen and Radha a Lola attempt the
world stealers the school bus
Tyson Kirino acquired respect and
Pattaya and I can't forget our pro hero
to your patrons the one and only
Gilgamesh nothing but a fan Jason Wilson
Odin Anatoly kazansky alpha do angel
Cruz team Sparky 65 Rohan Kapoor cricket
XP $30.00 beat Ted no Ted shelter Joel
Staunton very gucci jessica calif on
alicia actor emperor otaku and JCC waka
thank you all so much
if you enjoy our work you can support
more ray by going over to patreon common
emitter or and becoming a patron today
for as little as one dollar if you do so
you'll get your name featured in future
videos alongside these amazing people
right here and you'll even get access to
our private patron only discord where we
talk about anime life and of course dank
memes so check out patreon.com/lenguin
thanks again and until next time see you
space cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]